aspects plus pratiques en matière
automobile
les dernières mini création
préfigure-t-elle la vision des rues de
paris enfin décongestionner il y à
celles qui sont traditionnelles il y a
également des modèles plus originaux ils
permettent une vue panoramique et laisse
une place suffisante pour les bagages
[Musique]
on peut voir encore des prototypes
électriques qui présente l'avantagé
d'éviter la pollution de l'air leur
développement pourrait modifier le
visage de certains quartiers
interdiction est en fait à tout autre
modèle d'y pénétrer et d'y stationner on
peut même prévoir un parc de ses
voitures pour l'utilisation publique en
self-service payable par jeton
[Musique]